Spider-Man: No Way Home might just have served up
one of the most emotionally devastating endings in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe to date. And this
is coming from the franchise that gave us this.
"I don't know what's happening, I don't know-"
"I don't wanna go, sir, please, I
don't wanna go. I don't wanna go."
No Way Home concludes with the multiverse
breaking apart, forcing Doctor Strange
to do everything in his power to stop it from
crumbling. After cosmic cracks form in the sky,
silhouettes of various characters appear,
each ready to enter the MCU dimension.
It's at this point that Peter Parker realizes that
they can prevent the multiverse from breaking by
having Strange make the world forget who Peter
Parker is — including those he loves most.
Considering the hefty emotional weight to this
whole scene, you might be forgiven for having
missed some of the characters who appeared
within those interdimensional doorways.
They're kinda hard to make out,
and they don't appear for long,
but if you look closely enough, you may
be able to catch a few surprising cameos.
Right now, there's been no official confirmation
about who exactly appears in the cracks.
At first glance, they may even appear as
intentionally distorted images designed to
give the impression that they could be pretty much
anyone. However, for the keen comic book observer,
some of those silhouettes definitely
seem more recognizable than others.
The figure most likely to stand out in fans' minds
is that of Rhino, bearing a striking resemblance
to the comic book iteration of the character —
as opposed to Paul Giamatti's more mechanical
version from The Amazing Spider-Man 2. This,
of course, seems to suggest that the tear in
reality would have brought in many more variants
on Spider-Man villains than those fans know from
previous movies. And it seems like we might have
seen a few who haven't appeared on-screen at all.
Since seeing No Way Home, MCU fans and audiences
have suggested that some of the other villains on
display in the final showdown include Scorpion and
Kraven the Hunter. While these foes haven't suited
up on screen just yet, there have been teases to
suggest they could enter the live-action sphere.
Kraven, aka Sergei Kravinoff, is one of
the more obvious figures in No Way Home,
thanks to the spear the silhouette appears to
be holding. You can also make out some thickness
around the silhouette's shoulders and head, which
could be the mane of his signature lion's pelt.
The scorpion figure is a little more challenging
to make out, but it's easier to see once you
know it's there. This villain appears to be bent
over, with a tail that curves up just behind him.
In this appearance, it looks like Scorpion is
crawling as opposed to standing up, suggesting
that this is a slightly different version from
that which appears in the main comic books.
It's probably a good time for Marvel to
be referencing these particular villains.
Kraven is getting his own Sony-produced
movie in the near future, while Scorpion
was hinted at in Spider-Man: Homecoming.
In that movie, Mac Gargan appears as a
potential buyer for the Vulture's weapons. He
subsequently appears in the post-credits scene
for the movie, in which he attempts to learn
Spider-Man's real identity through Vulture.
"I got some boys on the
outside who'd love to meet him.
You know, take a picture, slice his
throat, put his head in the dryer…"
Seeing how No Way Home's ending has set up a
whole new era for the MCU's Spider-Man, it's
entirely within the realm of reason that Scorpion
might appear as a proper villain in the future.
While Kraven, Scorpion, and Rhino have been
the three most discussed villains from the
crackling sky scene, a few other famous comic book
characters are thought to have been spotted, too.
One of them is Black Cat — whose appearance
shouldn't come as much of a surprise,
since Spider-Man producer Amy Pascal has suggested
that the infamous thief is bound
for the big screen in the future.
There have also been some other obscure
guesses about who is hiding in the sky,
with some fans claiming to have seen Madame
Web, while others believe to have spotted the
multiverse-hopping vampire known as Morlun.
And who knows who else might yet be found?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.